it's a bit of a funky look it is well
you have to hand it to tutor they've
really really focused on great dials
great value if there was ever a brand
that could encroach on a rolex it would
be tudor absolutely it's its own
standalone brand this is not the poor
man's rolex
hey mr wonderful here with teddy again
in a really remarkable place we're in
the basement
of the
the bucharest store in new york the
flagship store maybe probably the
largest watch store in the world
pretty well
every brand here 20 brands plus
you can never find a shop experience
like this i want to focus on one
particular brand which i think has a
little controversy to it we're going to
talk about it it's tutor
now teddy i'm going to let you set the
pace here sure talk about tudor its
heritage and then let's debate where
this fits in the strata of brands right
now absolutely so let's start with the
history of tutor
we've talked about this in the past yes
and we've said but where is its market
position i think there's
what tudor originally was intended to do
by hans vilsdorf when he registered the
name 1926 and then eventually started
making watches in 1946 you had the
middle of the 20th century then they had
the affiliations with the marine
national
using a lot of of course rolex parts a
lot of names so they were emulating much
of the submariner they actually had two
submariners so there was a period where
tudor was just seen as that
50s we're talking about we're talking uh
60s 50s 60s 70s and even 90s or making
some mariners in the 60s and 70s
for many people including me
tudor was the entry-level rolex if you
couldn't afford a rolex you bought a
tutor with this brand assumption that
somehow it was the umbrella brand and
the quality of this entry-level piece
the tutor
was the let's call it for what it was
the poor man's rolex
now
that's what it was in the 60s as a brand
yeah hunsville's dwarf i mean you could
look at the quote that he had he was
looking for an entry-level position for
rolex without compromising the image of
rolex but what's happened and i think
there's two areas of tutor there was
a time when in the 90s i think they
really lost their way they're releasing
models like the hydro knot and other
things that were a little out there
they removed themselves from the us
market for a decade a brand like tutor
not even i never understood that well
they probably just were not selling
through but then something happened i
think they really thought about okay we
need to establish our own identity we
need to establish our own watches that
can speak to our history and also being
unique and i think we can talk about
that today now we don't have everything
on the table but i think if you had to
look at what spurred all this along to
change it was the tudor black pay so
this was released in 2012 i agree with
you i mean i will admit to one thing
twitter is now a stand-alone brand it's
found a price point sub five thousand
dollars three to five is usually where
they play mostly so they're stealing
share from a bunch of people that were
also in that space
and they've done something that really
matters to me and to collectors
they've really created great dials
they've got great dials there's lots of
selection a lot of good work being done
here and i can finally say with
certainty and i would never do this
unless i believed it this is not the
poor man's rolex anymore it's not it's
not even associated with rolex the same
way it was before in the in the markets
eyes it's its own standalone brand so i
gotta hand it to management clearly
marketing has worked for them people
think the watch is hip now it's a great
piece that you can afford for two three
four thousand dollars
and they make a really good movement
good caliber great dial and i think the
one thing that they'll speak to that is
the fact that if you a lot of rolex
buyers
if it was just say
an offshoot of roll accidents that's all
it was it didn't have any substance to
it then why would roxbury ever buy a
tutor but what i find is many rolex
buyers do buy tutor still yeah so that
does happen let's talk a little bit
about some watches though okay now we're
here in bucharer so i think we start
here now
2012 they come out with the black bay it
was originally unveiled 41 millimeter
case adam movements and then in 2016
they started unveiling in-house calibers
and then you just saw a barrage of new
models one of the models that they
released on the sports dive on the
sports dive watch so and then this is
going back to those big crown family of
dive watches it didn't hurt them that
all the other makers were going the same
direction
i mean dive got re well it still is it's
really big so this one is the largest of
the bunch we have that's the other thing
that tutor's done was they've
represented all the different sizes this
is 43. and look what it's made of this
is a bronze case so this is the bucher
blue edition so they released the 2016
the
brown dial version of the bronze case it
was in 43 and it does a couple things
different one of course you're getting
bronze three six nine dial larger case
format
immensely popular the blue core is is
marked on the back as being part of this
unique arrangement yep buchur blue
there's other brands that have also done
it i guess you see others uh it's a
beautiful piece there's no question
about it it's clear that they really
focused on bringing something in the
market that was going to be very
competitive price point on this teddy
that is just over four thousand dollars
and that's a phenomenal value for four
thousand dollars and what they do with
their bronze and what i've liked about i
don't know if you've ever i'm sure you
have like the bronze and its patina
effect like if you tarnish it it can
look
i mean it looks like the statue of
liberty at times for certain brands but
what tudor does is they have a different
alloy a lot of aluminum in the alloy
which allows it to have that consistent
hue longer than some other brand so i
want to start there that's like 20 so on
the table we mostly have black baits but
let's just keep going through some of
them another one that i love for around
three thousand dollars what can you get
from an everyday watch versatile could
be worn in a sporty environment could be
worn potentially with some dressy attire
maybe not with a full suit but you know
how to wear a sports coat could work the
tudor black bay yeah so this is two
black bay you have 36 you have a 41
these were unveiled in 2016 and i just
think for somebody that just wants a do
it all type of piece they don't maybe
like the dive watch format of the black
bag but they want something with that
style and of course design elements with
the hands it's a crossover piece it can
be a dress watch it can also be sporty
and you have that 36 option and one
thing i just want to talk about now in
the last six seven months the smaller 36
38 has become very very competitive in
terms of men's watches lots of guys are
getting smaller dials now because they
look great and it's something that
the trend kind of died for a few years
now it's coming back which shows when
you're collecting
you don't ever want to get stuck in one
time period you want to have lots of
different options i'm now buying 36s i
agree yeah this one is the 41 and then
also i mean 150 meters of water
resistance on this
you know but that's i mean i don't get
down past you know 100.
the rolex standard is 100 meters so i'm
just just saying yeah now moving on to
i think another part of
what tudor's done really well this was a
watch was released in 2018. this is
another black bay uh we're going to be
talking about a black bay here today but
it's for good reason this has changed
the brand completely this is the gmt
black bay gmt so this was released in
2018.
it's just over four thousand dollars so
you know what that's going to get
mistaken for oh you know exactly so this
one is more on the nose i will give you
this and this is starting to encroach on
the territory but why this was so
special was that there was ever a brand
that could encroach on a rolex would be
tutor absolutely and so this is an
opportunity to own a watch that when you
look across the room is going to look
like a gmt
and it in fact it really has that
heritage um at an incredible price point
the other thing i would say about that
now there is some more competition now
but when that was released so there's a
true people call it a true gmt and what
that refers to is when you are traveling
and you have a gmt watch
typically when you use off-the-shelf
calibers like a sw-330 from solida and
at a 28.93
there's no way to do this you pull out
to the first position and you can
isolate the hour hand so the same of
course rolex of course does that but for
four thousand dollars there are not many
brands that will do this and then say
hey i'm traveling to la i'm here in new
york city three hours back three hours
move the handbag three hours quick don't
happen i do that with my gmt all the
time and it's a fantastic feature moving
along
now we do have a couple others and this
is a personal favorite i'm actually
wearing one right now
we have
the black bay 58 so this was also
unveiled the same year as the gmt
uh so first
the line was the models that we have
here is a blue navy version which i have
on my wrist now in stainless steel and
on a bracelet and then this is another
watch this was actually released last
year
that case
is made of
silver
925 sterling silver
beautiful and you know that'll have
great patina over there oh yes and i
know i've seen some of these now getting
a little aged because they've been in
the markets seems like they're holding a
grayish style they call it taupe choke
it really really works with the silver
because the bezel also has that tonality
that is a fantastic combination a
beautiful piece and when we're talking
about where can tudor differentiate
itself and be different price point on
this just over four thousand dollars as
well so i mean this is really what the
story's about is these really eclectic
beautiful pieces with the inherent
quality in the movement you know it's
there and under five thousand dollars i
think it's so important people realize
you can start watch collecting at very
low price points and great get great
pieces manufacture caliber so they own a
manufacturing
movement provider can
and they're producing their mt calibers
inside of here 70-hour power reserves
these are all cosc certified the
majority of these on the table so
there's a lot going for it and i also
open case back
where do you see that from the rolex and
rolex tutor family that's very rare you
don't see it you don't see it and also
on a silver watch i mean come on so it's
it's a little different you know i don't
recall ever seeing anything in a rolex
first nut and silver it's actually not
open other than some really rare cellini
prince models i mean they don't do it
yeah they just don't do it so it's
another point they don't have to do it
they don't have to do it that's right
otherwise they do it that's that's true
i mean that's what competitors do they
try and get an up by just having
something in the back to look at but
rolex doesn't have to do it yeah okay
let's go on to a dress side maybe dress
sign all right so this is something i
actually own one of these too this is an
underrated watch now this
two thousand dollars yeah you want to
get a brand like tutor and if you talk
about brand equity i think this is as
strong as you can come by
in terms of this process very nice
bracelet too it is very nice so this is
a classic dress watch 1926 is the name
of that so that's kind of paying you
know honor to the original year that the
name was going to be trademarked yeah
in addition there's texture to this
style there is and which also gives it
kind of a little bit of a 3d element
and it does you know the thing about
these dials on dress watches you want to
make sure there's contrast between what
you're seeing what you're not seeing so
you can tell the time from the side of
your eye and that this this watch
definitely they call that an opel this
is my favorite version now there are
multiple different variations for ladies
all different sizes too
so you have 41 a 39 a 36 i mean there's
a lot to choose from with the sizing of
these and that's what i really like
about tutor and like these offerings
it's just a no nonsense two thousand
dollar uh dress watch and i also think
it does have some sporty upside you're
talking 100 meters of water resistance
you have that bracelet that's available
to it you could of course change out the
strap if you needed to i had to screw
down crown so that speaks to the waters
so that's that could be a capable just
everyday style launch this is just a
twin uh term that i think i think it's
probably
the most wearable of what we've got here
in terms of being good for everything
yep tuxedo t-shirt
works i think i think you can right
strap you could add some sizes
so you have a variety to choose from 36
36 available 39 41 you also have some
lady option that's 31 41 yep yep got it
all different sizes there fantastic
now a couple other ones
let's go a little funky and then we'll
talk about a new model that was just
released that we can speak to as well so
this is known as the heritage chrono
from twitter so back in the 1970s they
had a watch called the monte carlo bit
of a buzz on this piece which makes it
interesting because you know if you can
get your hands on one then you've got
something that's may get collectible at
some point people call it the monte
carlo because it almost looks like a
roulette wheel with the
it's a bit of a funky look it is
like very 70s very 70s
but
you know
look
it's got a lot going on on it and that's
probably why it's not going to do as
well as some of the other pieces i think
yes they also we don't have it here
today but the black bay chrono is i
would say for around five thousand
dollars maybe the best value for a swiss
entry level chronograph you talk about
the speed master speed master is at 6
300 for so this is this is a brand
that's duking it out with omega but
omega's moved up price point 20
they're taking a bit they're taking that
market share of like 2 000 to 5 000
they're really owning it
tutor is tutoring yes they're gaining
market share that tells you a little bit
about the watch industry they're
probably stealing some share from tag
right now tag breitling perhaps
moving up a little bit yes but that
price point is entry level for sure
and and obviously omega's feeling
confident enough and they should given
what's happened in the last couple of
years to kind of get in that five to ten
thousand dollar range look at that
snoopy that watch that they brought yeah
that's crazy yes absolutely no but look
also interesting i mean if you want
something a little more eclectic not
expensive
chronograph i get it
and then we'll close out with a new
model for 2021
this is known as the tudor black bay pro
now
again very similar to the gmt i look at
this and i definitely see some rolex in
here
are you kidding yeah i mean i see
vintage rollers exactly and what was
great was totally unplanned you picked
out a 1655 explorer ii that's exactly
what i get here you get the orange gmt
hand you get the fixed stainless steel
bezel on the outside 24 hours it's cool
yeah this is vintage
look of in the old days rolex did not do
ceramic bezels and so this was just
stainless bezel but which is absolutely
beautiful
this is my favorite of their pieces
currently isn't that beautiful yeah it
is 39 millimeters so that's 39. which i
like yep middle ground middle price
point again just over 4 000 as well i
mean that is probably a fantastic watch
i i you cannot go wrong with this at
that price it has it has you covered in
every scenario i i mean i love that size
some people were saying some things
about the thickness i i think it is
thick it is thicker it is thicker but
you've got a lot going on in this watch
true gmt again yeah
no you know for that price
gmt for that price and also such a
classic look
fantastic look you have to hand it to
tutor they've really really focused on
great dials great value lots of
interesting technology here to get true
gmt and under five grand says it all
yeah we haven't even looked at things
like the pelogos which is a full
titanium dive watch and they have this
cool marine national collaboration
you also have
full ceramic black bay full ceramic
watch so there's they really have become
the entry level best value i think okay
in this price range of two to five
thousand dollars i'd put them you know
really up against anybody i mean there's
other brands that i think of like an
aorus and of course like a long gene
that are also there but even them they a
little bit in terms of pricing they also
go down a little bit more than twitter
tutors
a little they're two thousand dollars
down if you think about it yeah they
don't hop out at five thousand they're
more of like that one thousand to say
three four thousand dollar range but so
basically if you're looking to enter the
watch market and you've got two to three
thousand to spend there's lots of
optionality with tutor that's why we did
the show today i really wanted you to
bring this forward because i'm really
looking for people to start their
journey that's the whole idea you want
to be in watch collecting you've got to
start your journey but i never want you
to borrow money to do it so you've got
to really think about what you what you
want about your beginning of the journey
there's no destination in watch
collecting only a journey it never ends
it's a horrible disease i hope you catch
it
thank you teddy marathon not a sprint
remember everybody take it slow
take care see you again soon